policy formal
meeting I have an emergency and standard
uh readout to do so bear with me
please there are no planned fire drills
so if the fire fire alarm goes off
please leave the building in an orderly
fashion through the nearest fire exit
please use either the fire exit through
the main doors of the hall or the fire
exit in the store room adjacent to the
stage the far assembly point is the
island in front of the main entrance to
the building please assemble
there please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building until give permission to do so
by the council staff please note that
the meeting will be live
streamed please switch off mobile phones
or turn them to silent
please please please note that toilet
and hand washing facilities are in the
foyer
area this is a specific note members of
the public while you are of course
entitled to film or take photographs
during this meeting can I please
emphasize to you that this should be
done without disruption to the meeting
and can only be done from a designated
area in the public
seating can I please therefore ask you
to raise your hand and clearly in the
air if you wish to take any photographs
or film this
evening that's a
no
okay members your voice will only be
captured on the live stream when your
microphone is switched on so please
remember to switch on your microphone
when you are invited to speak and switch
off again when not
speaking members voting will be done on
a show of hands in line with the
Constitution I will ask for a show of
hands for and then against
recommendations and we'll also ask for a
show of hands for those wishing to
abstain from
voting we can now move on with the
actual agenda item number one apologies
for absence
no apologies of been received
everybody's here it's a full
house agenda item two non-members
attending I can't see any District
counselors
attending town councel and a parish
counselor but no District
counselors agenda item number three
minutes of meeting held on the 27th of
July
2023 are these minutes agreed
members
question just one point chairman um I
probably think it will be best I'm
looking at item 145 Brownfield L
register I know we've got that coming up
in the next item so I would like to talk
on that rather than anything else on
here so as far as that's concerned this
is noted here but I would like to add
something to the next item thank
you thank you
[Music]
everybody else
happy me sub meeting
approved agenda item number four to
receive any Declarations of Interest
members are there any Declarations of
interest thank you chairman um as a
member of SE County Council and also a
member of Barling magnet Parish
Council
excuse me Riley Town council
member else
anyone Brownfield land register 2023
second
update members Daniel Gman will present
the officer's report as
follows thank you chairman uh members
you will hopefully recall that back in
July we uh we considered the Brownfield
land register 2023 at that meeting um
the action that came out of that meeting
was that we would uh review the register
uh to consider any sites that may have
been emitted that were worthy of
inclusion in that register uh we have
now held um a an exercise whereby
alternative sites could be considered
and so the item is now returning post
that
consideration uh I won't uh reiterate
what a r register is or the regulations
there as they said out in the report but
just to summarize the changes relative
to the previous version uh we're now
proposing to add lards Farmers site r
046 as well as extend the boundary to
site
r033 to include some lands to the rear
known as Limehouse
nurseries um there are some caveat set
out in the report members to do with
eligibility and clearly also to
emphasize that inclusion in the BR
register simply means that the council
considers that the site would be would
likely be suitable for development
likely be available for development and
that at least five dwellings could be uh
realized on the site uh so in that
context the sites that are in this uh
recommended register meet those
definitions um in total the Branford
land register 2023 as now updated
identifies a total of 33 sites which we
consider to meet the criteria for
inclusion together these 33 sites have a
minimum capacity of 964 dwellings uh
which is a judgment and does not bind
planning applications in the future but
nevertheless is there to inform the
local plan around brownford land
capacity and just for members interest
uh that represents a 36% increase in
brownford land capacity compared to the
previous register so U clearly we are um
doing a lot here to identify Brownfield
land Capac
capity so the recommendation on this
item chairman is that the brownford land
register which is attached at appendix a
to this item is noted and published on
the council's website uh if there are
any questions or clarifications then I'm
more than happy to take them now thank
you Council
Ward thank you very much chairman um I'd
like to thank uh Daniel uh and the team
for going through the items and
recognizing uh that some needed to be
expanded I would also like um to be
noted an item uh from the past actually
from the previous
administration um I don't know if Daniel
can confirm this to me um that one of
the major policies that was in the last
Administration was Brownfield par
Brownfield and contaminated sites uh to
be taken as a priority
uh do you recognize that statement
please
Daniel for you chairman sorry chairman
is this um is this relevant to the the
current report that's what I would
ask well I'll try and answer both
questions just to say that I'm aware
that that was a a priority of the
previous administration but in terms of
the context of this report I think
Council newort probably has a point that
we we're straying off the um the the
objective But to answer your question
fairly Council Ward um yes I do
recognize that as a policy
ambition thank thank you very much
chairman um again then I I hope that
this new Administration will also be
taking that
priority as well and we'll be taking
that on board and I hope you will you
know Champion that policy going forward
to be looking at Brownfield Park
Brownfield and contaminated sites as a
priority but if I can please go on on
I'm now referencing
mppf uh and I'm going to
quote the mppf states that planning
policies and decisions should promote
the effective use of land making as much
use as possible of previous developed or
Brownfield land it goes on to instruct
local planning authorities to give
substant poal weight to the value of
using suitable Brownfield land and
support appropriate opportunities to
remediate despoiled degraded derel
contaminated or unstable
land uh I would ask that to also be
noted as part of our policies chairman
uh that is within the mppf as part of a
debate that took place I can tell you
when it was on the 9th of February
2023 which absolutely unanimously agreed
that this should be part of the mppf and
should be something universally taken by
all authorities so I ask that that be
noted and entered in as a part of the
record that goes into our IMR and our
policies if that could be recognized
please Council
nle yes chairman um what I'd like to
know is is councilor Ward moving a
motion to have that included in in in
this as one of these
recommendations thank
you I would like to thank Council of
Newport for making that suggestion yes I
would like to make that a motion
please okay let's get the wording
exactly right then uh without going into
paragraphs I would suggest okay
the nppf states that planning
policies and decisions should promote
the effective use of land making as much
use as possible of previously developed
or Brownfield land it goes on to
instruct local planning authorities to
give substantial weight to the value of
using suitable ground Field Land
and support appropriate opportunities to
remediate despoiled degraded derel
contaminated or unstable
land sorry point of order chairman are
we allow the recording
presumably not doing short sorry on a
point of order I'm asking if we allowed
to put a motion to report which is just
for
noting Miss
sorry chairman um I was asking on a
point of order whether we are allowed to
put a motion on a report which is just
for
noting the recommended actually goes on
to say uh it will appear on the
council's council's rep website as a
document so I don't believe it's uh
simply a noted
[Music]
item you turn your off sorry
coun oh okay Council Foster please go
first oops I was going to Second the
proposition than coun
foxer
second okay I'd like to say something
myself okay
the reld register has been through
iterations
and we're going to take a vote on it
tonight if you're not happy with it as
it is then you make the appropriate vote
[Music]
okay thank you chairman um I'd just like
to ask the officer does this change any
of the context of this report
[Music]
please in as much as we are just looking
to note and publish this brownford land
register I'd say possibly not um however
I think I understand the the suggestion
Within the the second proposal or the
proposal so I'll leave that for members
to decide but uh in terms of the
recommendation on the brownford land
register I don't believe that's
suggested for changing
so thank you
done okay well I think we take a vote on
the motion then I think oh sorry another
one I can't see a
light okay so uh the motion put forward
by Council Ward seconded by Council
F want take a vote on that all those in
all those four please show your
hands thank you thank you all those
against please show your
hands any
extensions
[Music]
okay the final vote is mine as
chairman and I'm
[Music]
against yes uh thank you chairman I
would like my vote counted as in support
of government policy on the mppf and
recognize that this was rejected by this
Council thank
you well let me just qualify that the
mppf is a massive document um this is a
part of it there are lots of other parts
of it that cover the
subject councilor Rees thank you chair I
just one the reason being why I um
abstained on this is because I'm I got
to be honest I'm a little bit confused
as to why this come forward because if
it's in the mpbf we've got to adhere to
it anyway so I'm a little bit sort of
puzzled if I'm honest exactly my
[Music]
feels councilor Ward yes thank
you the reason I've asked this to be
noted and put in because I think it's
important within our policies do not
actually show this particular statement
within our Brownfield policies at all I
found it I've seen it and I would like
it added but as the vote has gone you
have decided as a council and as uh a
group to disregard it so I would assume
that uh you are not taking as a priority
I have to assume this now that this
Administration is not making the use of
Brownfield contaminated sites and
previously used Brownfield sites as a
priority that is my assumption now
quite of order chairman I think this is
we're talking about a Brownfield
register not policy and I think that's
outside the scope of what we should be
discussing I agree which is why I voted
against it I don't think it's necessary
this is document isn't driven by the
local plan it's a registry document
annually done every year and uh
councilor Foster i' I'd like my vote
recorded as well please I'm sorry
tet I'd like my vote named as well
please would like V sorry on a point of
order I think if you read the
Constitution you must say that
immediately at the end of the vote if
you want it
recorded other people were speaking I
have been refused to vote on that basis
before I think we should be
consistent okay well we've had to
vote it is going to be recorded as
requested that is the end story we now
move
on I have a question I'm sorry I have a
question on a sub different subject
about Brownfield
side
okay okay the point of the Bradford
register is to keep it
updated um what I'd like to know is how
frequently we are going to look at that
and update it um personally I think it
should be at least every six months I'd
like to be it to be reviewed every three
mon months um during the course of a
period of time that may not need to be
uh changed but I think it needs to be
reviewed certainly in those per time
periods so I'd like to um request that
uh um some clarification on how quick
and how soon the register will be
updated going forward on a continuous
basis Dan Goodman can you take that
please yes bearing in mind we are
sticking strictly to to all the rules of
planning tonight and then no doubt it is
dictated somewhere how often we do it
thank you chairman um yes so the the
brownford land register must be updated
at least annually um I'm not aware that
there is any thing prohibiting it being
updated more than more frequently than
annually the only caution I would add
chairman is that the the way that the
council and most councils if not every
Council monitors housing completions is
such that actually you would not observe
much change on a frequent review um the
odds of a new planning permission being
granted for a site that isn't already on
the register in any quarter is fairly
small we might be talking about one site
or or such so I would advise if I can
against a very frequent review because
I'd suggest that actually um the the
rate of change does not warrant that um
I have no objection in principle to a
six-monthly review um
however I'd advise that perhaps that's
um a matter that we can kind of discuss
when we get closer to that review window
um in the sense of if there is enough
change to Warrant that being taken back
to the committee at the very least we
will of course carry on updating it at
least
annually thank you good Mike would you
come back on that yes I'd like to have
it at least every six months there
there's unlikely to be a change I I
accept that but I do think it just needs
to be reviewed and if there is any
changes that we just need to be made
aware of
them what I might suggest chairman is
that there's probably a way in which
members can be advised of updates
without necessarily a wholesale review
of the register so I'm happy to commit
you know in terms of um noting from this
meeting that we will give members at
least a six monthly update on Brownfield
land capacity but uh only look to update
the register um by default on an annual
basis unless a need arises I think were
there to be a flurry of new sites for
example then we may well be able to
bring a review sooner but I'm just um
trying to advise some caution on
proportionality of work involved that's
okay you happy with that MK yeah I'm
happy to accept that thank you thank
you
thank you chairman just um a couple of
questions and I'm sure we all know the
anwers to these but I think it's very
important I asked them in a public
meeting so that members of public are
also aware of the answer with regards to
the Brownfield register this is a
register of Brownfield sites and can you
the officer confirm that just because
there is a found Brownfield register of
these sites it doesn't mean we compelled
to use these sites secondary um just
because these sites are in a Brownfield
register can you confirm whether or not
we are predetermined planning permission
it gives extra status in a planning
permission whether or not these could be
passed thank
you yeah thank you um so to answer those
questions probably um together um having
a site on the BR for register confers no
special status to that site it would
still um need to be considered where a
planning application to come forward
where but that's at development
committee or otherwise
so uh the test that is set out in
regulations is around likely
superability and that's a very light
policy approach based you know broadly
on whether or not there are any major
reasons why planning permission is very
unlikely to be you know be forthcoming
whether that's uh insurmountable flood
risk as an example what it doesn't do in
that test of likely suitability is
consider all the very many things that
planning application would need to
consider which Frank Frank L we would
not know about until that planning
application was submitted I.E whether a
sufficient Road access could be provided
um so it's all about proportionality and
certainly there's no um legal basis for
this binding a planning application uh
and I'm sure there are many very many
examples across the country of of uh
sites and around register ultimately not
being able to achieve a planning
permission um so in that context it
doesn't bind the council in any way um
ultimately it will still need to be
determined against planning policies um
if a planning application were to come
forward thank
you that's War thank you very much uh
bearing that answer in mind um I did
notice uh on a couple of these you have
put Cod you have actually put something
in there you know that um even though it
is on the planning list um it's down to
actually when a plan an application
comes in whether it's viable or
sustainable and it has to go through all
these various things but again taking
that into
consideration uh I guess the reason the
government requires us to have a
Brownfield site register and why is in
the mppf with regard to the priorities
of a Brownfield site I take it that
works together in that we recognize we
do have sites which are Brownfield we do
recognize in the MP PF that uh the
government requires us to take
Brownfield sites as a priority before
using other sites so I guess it does
match up doesn't
it so to answer that question Council a
ward so taking the Brownfield register
slightly out of the equation it's fair
to say that if a site comes forward for
planning permission on a Brownfield site
then the council is obliged to apply
National policy which says which br
provides broad support for delivering on
brownford sites however clearly that
needs to be weighed against all the very
many policies in the Rochford local
development framework and in the
national uh planning policy framework so
yes the brownford nature of these sites
provides a um if you're looking at it in
a scales sense it provides a weight in
favor of any site irrespective of
whether it's on the Brownfield register
or not uh but it doesn't mean that every
brownford site will automatically always
get planning permission because there
are no doubt Brownfield sites which for
very you know for other reasons are very
unsuitable for development
so
okay after I think uh since we've had an
extension to the previous meeting in the
form of a workshop and a second Workshop
to discuss this document we're now at
the point where we're going to vote on
the
document that the Brownfield L register
2020 3 attached at appendix a is noted
and published on the council's website
so we now go to
voting those members in favor can you
please raise your
hands thank
you
unanimous that's unanimous and
passed
[Music]
we move on to agenda item number
six new local plan evidence base
Economic Development needs assessment
2023 again officer Daniel Goodman will
present the officer's report thank you
Dan thank you chairman members this is
an item for information surrounding uh a
piece of the local plan evidence base
which has recently been been concluded
so members may be aware but Economic
Development needs assessments are
documents which are required to inform
local plans uh there's quite a lot of
guidance sent out in the planning
practice guidance about how local
authorities should seek to assess the
future need for economic development
floor space um just just for clarity
typically these kinds of Assessments
will look at the future need for floor
space for uh what used to be called the
kind of bclass employment uses so um in
short that's typically officing
industrial floor space and floor space
for
warehousing so this uh assessment forms
uh an update to previous works the
council and the committee noted uh an
Edna uh or an economic development needs
assessment back in 2017 which was
undertaken at the South eics level this
is a new assessment which only covers
Rochford uh it covers the period
principally to 2040 in the first
instance um just to clarify um longer
term projections than that are
inherently unreliable um because there's
quite a lot of Naval gazing involved as
you'd imagine so hence why it's only
2014 in the first instance but no doubt
the kind of document that needs to be
regularly
updated so the edner update has been
prepared to identify a number of things
one of which is the extent to which
existing land and allocations are
helping to meet short and long-term
needs for employment space so in other
words whether developments at say
airport Business Park and arterial Park
are likely to meet short and long-term
needs for that kind of floor space or
not uh the extent to which new land or
allocations might be required in the new
local plan to help meet that um that
need I.E whether or not there's a
shortfall in the long
term and also to look at the types of
employment space that are likely to be
required and that's why I say there's a
there's a split in the document
throughout around officing industrial
and wear
housing uh so I will be honest chairman
these types of modeling U modelbased
assessment ments are fairly new uh
number heavy uh they are based generally
on lots of number crunching and they do
takes a scenario based approach which is
what is required in planning practice
guidance to look at what might be um
needed in the future so what the
document does not do is set out a single
scenario which it is recommending in a
sense it is providing options and
scenarios um from which the council can
then make informed judgments the future
when it has a bit more uh insight into
its local plan
strategy uh so I will just summarize the
findings um which is to say and I won't
read out all these numbers but there
there is a table one in the report which
sets out uh the broad employment land
requirements that each of the four
modeled scenarios would require and
whether or not that generates a surplus
and shortfall to
2040 um in short at the moment what what
this is suggesting is that the district
is due to over Supply quite
substantially on General industrial
floor space but it may well struggle to
meet its long-term needs for lighter
industrial and officing floor space uh
in that context and I think I probably
said this in committee meetings before I
think the district has quite a
significant macro supply of employment
space for the future but what is going
to be quite key for the local plan is
looking how micro needs might be met so
that might be typ indiv ual types of
employment floor space of a certain size
or stock which are not being met on say
airport business park or arterial Park
as well as kind of more modern methods
of providing employment space like live
work hubs um and flexible office space
which is not very well cated from the
district at the moment so this is this
is just one piece of the puzzle chairman
to inform the new local plan I would
also just like to advise members that um
the team have been working on a supply
side complement to this study
uh through an employment land study
which is looking at the sufficiency of
the district's existing employment sites
industrial Estates and so on uh and
providing a little bit more of a
qualitative analysis around some of that
which will um if you excuse this analogy
um you know close off some of that
puzzle by providing the other pieces and
I expect that that employment land study
will come to a committee meeting um in
the next couple of months ideally uh so
I I'll stop there as I say uh chairman
the item is for information so I'm not
aware that there's a specific
recommendation attached to it but
nevertheless I'm more than happy to take
any questions or observations about this
item um now really thank
you thank you Dan are there any more
questions before we move to the next
item councilor Ward thank you very much
chairman um yeah I welcome this report I
I know the quality of Lich Fields is is
very much in depth and again from past
experience it's very important to have
these uh evidential documents that we've
got to work on so that as we start to
work on our local plan we can then
understand where we need whatever we
need um I I think one of the things that
is becoming very apparent is we're
looking at now jobs moving to where
people live rather than people moving to
where the jobs are and I think where
we're talking about local towns local
cities and local communities I think
that is something even though a lot of
people are trying to get people to
return to work uh and such like I think
in a lot of the office situations I
think a lot of them are looking to
transport the jobs out so they're
bringing the jobs to people as opposed
to the other way around um and I guess
as as Daniel has elucidated within the
report that um it is a case of looking
at the micro situation where somebody
doesn't have a sufficient place to
actually work at home due to
circumstances and maybe needs to have a
small office or something like that
where they can work from just go to
locally so that is something that we may
have to consider but I think the report
is excellent and I think it will help us
thank you chairman thank you
counc Council
Hoy uh yes thank you um I had a number
of questions I think some have been
answered some by Daniel Goodman and I
think um C W was probably touching on
one of the SEC one of the other
questions I had which was around the um
small scale office or flexible
co-working space um and this probably
goes not just for that but for other
areas as well I
mean I think it's identified that we
need that I know through Economic
Development I've spoken to our officers
and they said that is something that
they think we need how do we write this
is the question I suppose everyone wants
to know how do we write policy to
encourage
that that's what we're supposed I
suppose that's what're doing $64,000
Question probably I just wondered if you
have any ideas on that yeah thank you
Council ho so just in terms of um the
edner update I think it kind of exists
at at that macro scale so in a sense it
it deals with employment land in use
classes and so it it's very helpful for
certain probably less helpful for
splitting into that massive use class
into then types and stock I think
fundamentally there's some strategic
decisions to be made as part of the
local plan to say if we identify that
there might be a need for new employment
stock or even re generation of existing
employment sites um we could quite
easily write policies which mandate the
types of employment space that we would
expect to be delivered on there part of
it is obviously led by the market and a
lot of this is Rel on having willing Aid
willing developers and others attached
but generally speaking if there's a an
economic need for something I.E it will
fill uh and it will be viable and
commercial that I think there's a lot we
can do in policy writing to mandate um
where new land might be required or uh
even within policies for retaining
existing land about how the council
would support the principle for those
types of spaces being developed the
other side of it which I can Al speak to
I guess without going too much off the
subject as you know in terms of economic
development is obviously as you say
Council Hoy is working with people
outside of the local plan to try and
realize those opportunities which is a
bit of a wider Council um aspect but
nevertheless I think the local plan is
an important part of that because no one
wants to invest in where there is no
land or opportunity available so that's
why it's important I think that the
policy is very clear about what the
council expects um so there's probably a
point chairman in the near future when
we talk about policies and making sure
that those Economic Development policies
for the local plan are capturing the
types of employment space we consider a
needed at a micro
level thanks
then thank you I just add one further
question if that's okay which hopefully
is as easy as one of the other ones to
answer um you make sure about commercial
property market review which the review
was to provide a market led to Cent
check of the findings is that
a sense check is that going to come
forward as a report eventually or have I
missed it within this is what I ask you
really that's the only other question I
had thank you yes so the so that um
property market review is a separate
piece of work which is ongoing at the
moment so essentially Lich fields are um
talking uh with our support with
probably um eight or nine prominent
local property agencies around Market
opportunities where they see the future
so so that's kind of the the local
subjective view of what we have here
which is the numerical position so what
that won't do is say well we need to
manually adjust the objective figures
because that wouldn't be very defensible
but what it will do is provide a
document which complements this and says
we've run this past property market
reviews they've they've noted the
findings and they've made the following
comments and that might be to say that
they think scenario 2 is the best to the
four or that might be you know and so
it's through that what we aim to do is
basically make sure that we make
informed decisions based on if you like
real world um the real world experiences
of local property Market agencies
obviously put through the lens of the
local plan and the council um to make
sure it's objective but nevertheless to
provide a little bit more insight to
inform this so that will come forward to
the committee in due course chairman I
think it's not a massive piece of work I
suspect it probably will be done before
the end of the year um so it will come
forward when uh possibly at the same
meeting I'm looking at colleagues now
possibly the same meeting the employment
land study which would seem to make
sense to me right thank
you
thanks Council stepped up thank you
chairman um at another meeting today
there was some interesting information
came out was the Essex wide um the
unemployment situation is around 23,000
if I remember correctly and the
availability of jobs is around 50,000 so
there is far more jobs out there than uh
than people that are in need of is that
t how is that equated down to our area
and is that taken into account within
this
assessment so uh in terms of long-term
projections obviously this is a
long-term assessment based on what is
expected to be needed over to the period
of 20 2040 the labor Supply scenario
which is scenario four is looking at
Future labor force demographics which
will include some assumptions around
employment rate employability Etc so
that scenario in particular is very
driven by expected changes in the
employment Market what I would say is
it's quite hard for a long-term
assessment like this to take into
account the current picture but
certainly in terms of the picture as is
expected to evolved to 2040 that very
much is part and parcel of these
assessments so I'm sure that
the employment rate will change and get
better I'm sure we're due Peaks and
troughs in that period but this is a
kind of averaged out Horizon scan um but
particularly scenario four is probably
the more interesting part of that with
respect to your question Council step to
around that is the scenario that's very
much driven by changes in the labor
market thank you I think councilor war
was before
you thank you chairman um yeah just
coming back to what council H said
uh in regards to micro uh development um
there must be an opportunity on new
developments to actually consider having
a hub specifically Hub developed within
new developments that would actually
facilitate uh the type of small office
now we're not talking about people who
go to work as Engineers or uh skilled
guys like that but we're talking to
people who would like to be in an office
in
environment away from town can go to it
locally and that probably has a
cafeteria or something like that and it
can be used can be mixed use so it's not
just for that item but I would suggest
maybe that's something we should look to
uh when we look at policies coming
forward in regards to new developments I
know we consider schools we consider uh
medical facilities maybe that's one
thing that we can consider just to add
on to Council of hoy's you know thoughts
in regards that that could be something
we could look at for developers to
provide which we know would be used as
opposed to possibly a school or a
medical center which is often just left
vacant because the various authorities
don't particularly wish to take them
up thank you
councilor thank you chairman I'm not
sure it's appropriate question at this
point but is the imminent departure of
the director of place like to have any
impact on the progress of the
plan well done T that's under riew at
the moment I'm talking to Jonathan about
that situation um it's was anticipated
to some extent and the recruitment is
already underway and has been for a
while um I'm keeping a close eye on it
and in fact I'm meeting Jonathan again
later in the week um to talk about that
very thing so I can't be definitive at
the moment but clearly it's something we
could do without I guess changing
changing jockies at any particular time
and in particular this quite crucial
time that we're approaching so I will
update you when I know thank you
cheers I was I was doing quite well
earlier
on okay um members
is this document
noted
not
sorry oh you done me another note of
it okay agenda item seven new local plan
evidence-based this one is retail
Leisure needs assessment update
2023 once again officer Daniel Goodman
will present the officer's report over
you Dan thank you chairman um so members
a fairly similar um assessment will be
at this time it's looking at the
long-term needs for future retail and
Leisure floor space um so um to carry on
my kind of planning jargon this is
mostly looking at floor space um that is
in the new class E which takes into
account a lot of what um has been kind
of termed Town Center uses so things
around retail Cafe restaurants Etc um so
the council's previous source of
evidence on retail Leisure needs was the
South eics retail study which again was
published in
2017 uh we have needed to update this
study to reflect a number of changes
since um not least the intention to
produce a plan over a longer time period
which means the previous study was
becoming less reliable as well as
obviously quite fundamental changes to
retail and Leisure markets that uh
things like the co pandemic um have
influenced so um what the retail Leisure
needs assessment assessment essentially
does is take a scenario based approach
again this time two scenarios which are
based on differing levels of assumptions
around housing growth um and project
forward what is likely to be required in
terms of both food and well food and
beverage floor space which as it sounds
like is um retail floor space selling
food and drinks comparison retail floor
space um and convenience retail floor
space so it picks up
um a lot of differences in the different
types of retail floor space between say
um places you might buy Goods um
infrequently like electronics shops or
Furniture shops and then um the far more
frequent trips to um supermarkets for
example it also picks up um an
assessment of long-term need for
commercial Leisure floor space I think
I'll be honest with that one and say
that's a slightly harder thing to model
because obviously commercial ledure
floor space takes into account quite a
lot of different types of activity
whether that's um kind of commercial
sport to um cinema theaters things like
this so um nevertheless that's um a
guide based on assessment around what
the local population growth could likely
support but I would caution that figure
slightly just because it's hard to
provide a bit of a breakdown as to what
that might look like in
practice uh so uh I will just read out
the summary findings so the retail
Leisure floor space um need for food and
beverage floor space 2040 is around 5 to
6,000 square meters comparison retail
floor space to 2040 is very modest
around 650 to 18800 square meters um and
in the long term considered to be
negative which implies that it's over
supplied at the moment relative to
Consumer
demand um a need for 56 6 to 734 meters
of convenience retail floor space which
again is projected to be negative in the
short term and then a need for 3,270 to
3,960 square meters of commercial
Leisure floor space so like the other
assessment chairman this will inform the
local plan by giving us an understanding
of how much retail and Leisure floor
space we might need to be planning for
as part of our new local plan some
councils in their local plans do
specifically allocate land for new
retail and Leisure floor space which
might for example a new Supermarket so
that is an option available to the
council as part of its strategy
considerations which obviously we will
get to over time
um I will also say just similar to the
economic development needs assessment
again really which is that this is
obviously a demand side assessment it's
very numbers driven but the team are
looking at Town Center health checks at
the moment to look at some of the more
qualitative stuff around the the health
of our town centers and policy options
for improving those uh again again this
is an item uh for information chairman
so I don't believe there is a specific
recommendation but again very happy to
answer
questions thank you
Daniel are there any more questions on
this particular
one Council Ward thank you very much
sorry
Mike that's my mistake Mike ask first
okay started where you going then thank
you Vice chairman um are we going to be
look at an economic review of You Know A
District um has that been looked at I
know we're looking at the various
different parts but I mean a real
economic view of of incomes um and
potential you know uses and also looking
at where how can I put it companies will
decide to come in because it's viable or
not is that something that we could
consider as as a further look in depth
as to the the realities of our own
situation I think to be honest Council
Bo it's not something that's planned I I
think if we could understand maybe what
the the driving purpose of that might be
then we can obviously consider that I I
say it's quite difficult um but as part
of the commercial property market review
which I mentioned on the previous item
that is very much engagement with with
agents so I would say that that would be
a fairly good proxy for Market interest
and what the market is looking to
deliver in terms of economy but in terms
of a council or should I should say a
strategic planning Le Economic Review
it's not something that's currently
planned um at the
moment Council wall thank you chairman
would that be considered bearing in mind
all the various problems that we've gone
through over the last two three
years
sorry I got
distracted well I can I can respond in
as much as to say I think if we if we if
there was a clear purpose to doing it
and it made sense to do it in the
context of the timetable and the program
then you know we can consider
opportunities to to do kind of more
evidence based around that stuff but I
think at this point in time I probably
wouldn't recommend it as a short-term
priority but but clearly you know I'm
happy to take advice from the committee
on that but I think at the moment I
think we're there's other things we're
prioritizing right now if I'm being
truthful counil
SE yes thank you chairman um you
mentioned there about Leisure and for
space for leisure a great deal of our
Leisure industry around Rockford
district is what I would term as green
leisure uh outside not necessarily
requiring fla space sorts of things I'm
Thinking of U in my particular area i'
got an awful lot of horses um around my
area there's an awful lot of water so
how do you take into account those
particular types of leisure Industries
and how can we support those types of
Industries uh Leisure areas um going
forward with the
plan thank you councilor stepto so I I
would say that this Pro this this type
of study is probably not the appropriate
study to to look at that um in terms of
um why we need a good understanding of
the amount of leisure floor space we
might need to plan for is because there
may be a need to allocate land
specifically for this um floor space in
order for those needs to be met I think
if I'm being honest in terms of that
green Leisure green tourism aspect a lot
of those uses are already provided for
in National policy even in the greenbell
so they're considered it they're
considered appropriate or not
inappropriate development in the green
belt and so they happen organically
generally without necessarily needing a
local plan to direct them and I'm not
aware of many local plans which
specifically look to allocate land for
green Leisure unless there was a very
specific project um so I'd say the local
plan policies can provide support for
green tourism green Leisure which they
already do in in the most part but I
think it's difficult
in the context of this item to imagine
an evidence-based piece of work which
looked at Green Leisure and green
tourism because it's quite hard to work
out I think what the role of the local
plan might be on that I think possibly
that might if there's a desire for
something like that that might be
something that's possibly bigger than
the local plan in that context um if
that makes
sense yeah my thought was that for
example if you've got a um a a a yach
club for example to encourage them to
develop their facilities far more that
type of thing is what I would starting
to think
about yeah thank you if I could just add
to that well I mean that the the way
that that could be dealt with is that as
part of the new local plan clearly there
were policies that will need to be
written around what will and won't be
considered appropriate development so
it's in the council's gift to write
policies which state broad support for
um green leisure development or green
tourism development so um you could
write or the council could write
policies which are broadly supportive of
that kind of activity it's probably not
the role of the local plan to actually
go out and encourage those people
directly to come forward planning
applications but certainly planning
policies can be crafted to encourage
appropriate development if it if there
is an ambition to do
that happy with that mik yeah okay
councilor
H yeah thank you I think um one of the
questions was been answered by the last
question um can you give them me an idea
of what 6 6,000 square meters looks like
and can you tell me what the difference
is between food and beverage retail and
convenience retail because I would
thought in my head they're the same but
obviously they're not thank
you yeah thank you Michael in terms
of in terms of I'd probably have to um
thinking I mean I'm sorry to go to
hectares but I know so 6,000 square
meters would be about 0.6 hectares so
it's quite a considerable amount of
land um I can't really easily off the
top of my head give you a comparative
for what that might be I'd love to be
able to tell you what the size this Hall
is at the moment um I am connected to
the internet I don't know whether or not
I'm allowed to go and Google um size of
a football pitch but possibly that might
be a good place to start but um yeah in
terms of in terms of the
differences um between the two uh
between the different types of
um
uh um Whatchamacallit in terms of
different types of retail floor space so
to my understanding food and beverages
is more food and beverages you would
consume on the premises so you're
talking about really cafes and
restaurants so food and beverage retail
is a bit of a misn Noma in a sense orbe
it's an accepted industry term
convenience uh retail is your
supermarkets your um news agents for
example where you would buy food and
drink to then go and uh consume at home
typically so that's the main difference
according to google a football pitch is
around 7,000 square meters I don't know
if that's correct so that's probably
about what we're talking about here if
that's if that's massively out then I
will advise members after the meeting
but um but yeah I I I think it's fair to
say as a general comment not
withstanding the uh projections for um
food and beverage retail retail floor
space the need for the other types of
retail floor space is fairly modest um
largely being met by existing facilities
in the most part uh and part of that
clearly is a is a symptom of what's
happening to the retail sector generally
um with a massive shift obviously to
online shopping a lot of people get
their groceries delivered now which
isn't great for the big floor plate
supermarkets in some senses so um whilst
I think logically we might say the more
people you have the more floor space you
need I think part of that being eaten
Away by wider Trends in the industry to
to actually move away from bricks and
mortar
facilities so potentially and I'm going
to say a figure which may be wrong now
because I can't remember the figure but
we used to have a policy of say of say
of 70 70% retail in the town center but
so we could potentially say 60% retail
and that we reduce the retail which
isn't as is going to be under over
Supply anyway and that could be taken up
by
food and beverage potentially or Leisure
is that the case as one example of what
we could do yes so I I think that's
where the Town Center health checks that
the rest of the team are working on will
be really useful because what we be able
to monitor is changes to floor space and
use classes over time I'd say it's a
little bit of a it's a balancing
exercise because what what the council
won't want to do is set out policies
which um accept that retail is no longer
necessarily going to be the king in town
centers and therefore accelerate the
loss of retail from the town centers the
other side of that coin is if the mar if
the retail Market is struggling or not
coming forward to take over vacant units
at the same time what we don't want is a
is a massive rise in vacancies in town
centers because there isn't the demand I
think where government are very much
going with this and why Class E now
exists is that essentially government
want it to be so that you could change
from retail to a cafe or to to a
restaurant without needing planning
permission and so in that context
actually the days of councils having a
lot of fine grain control over youth
class in town centers are probably
behind us and so in a sense I don't want
to put a negative note on it but Town
Center policies and local plans are
probably less influential than they
might have been in the past but
certainly that kind of policy ambition
for a percentage I think May well stay
and what the piece of work the team are
working on will do is look at what are
the appropriate what we might call
primary shopping Frontage secondary
shopping Frontage what are the cores of
the centers that we really want to keep
and are there peripheral parts that
actually through natural attrition we
might accept a lost to alternative uses
um that said you know and i' wear a dual
hat in this game you know I don't know
whether or not this is the consensus
view but I'd say you know RA in
particular is persevering fairly well in
terms of a lack of vacancies but it's
clearly something we want to keep an eye
on and make sure that planning policies
aren't a reason for more vacancies and I
think Dan wants to add to that so I I'll
leave it
there thanks Dan um yeah Dan has covered
most of it but I suppose it's just you
know whilst whilst Class E allows for a
lot of flexibility so it is a lot harder
to you know to get a real handle on you
know ensuring as a certain percentage of
you know a forly A1 retail compared to
you know Leisure or food and beverage is
still something I think we want to keep
quite a close eye on um members probably
that in recent years um there's been a
relaxation of permitted development
rights so it is now you know quite easy
to convert Class E commercial uses to to
residential for example and there are
some advantages of additional
residential in town centers because it
can you know boost footful and so on but
at the same time there are you know
there are fewer um there are fewer prior
approval points now and fewer safeguards
to you know to prevent for example a an
empty shop unit on a High Street from
you know from becoming a flat so it's
something you want to keep a close eye
on and you know if if if you know we do
notice over time you know a bit of a
trend of loss of commercial space in in
town senters that was previously you
know in a in a primary second retail
Frontage you know going over to
residential then perhaps it's you know
something we can try and make a more
specific intervention such as an article
four Direction but that has to be
very Justified yeah it has to be very
compelling these days because um
well yeah yeah government have um you
know have um made
it thank you
down you had your hand up
first thanks on um page
20 where um it draws the conclusions on
the commercial Le Leisure
uses it it the report says about we need
increased floor space but what about the
spatial distribution of that floor space
when will that come in Dan because
that's very sort of uh General
generalized there um and we see that in
some of the recommend or suggestions
there are a small theater thank God we
save the ma Hall and
um I'm quite Keen to understand you know
how that would devel
yeah thank you Council Newport so um
usefully a lot of this projections are
based on um Experian data um um who some
of you might know they're mostly a
credit agency but they do clearly do
other stuff and what they have are
models which take a kind of zonal
approach and so I think it's in the
appendix to the appendix but there is
some information that is based on kind
of zones of the district and it wouldn't
be too difficult orbe it possibly
introducing an element of unreliability
which we might to consider but it
wouldn't be impossible to um consider
the distribution of the need based on
those zones so they are retail catchment
zones so um there is a map um it looks
like it's about page 34 34 of the um
appendix um which shows those and they
probably don't follow many recognizable
features but what they would allow is
for us to consider um what a ra need
might be what a hotley need might be
what a Rochford Town need might be so in
that context there will there's probably
some disaggregation possible based on
retail
catchments um which can then inform
where um that need is arising from some
of that will also clearly depend on the
housing strategy for the local plan
because clearly if the housing strategy
um develops more in one area than
another you might expect obviously an
increase in retail demand in that area
so um that's my longwinded way of saying
that there is uh the underlying data is
geographic and so in that sense it
should be possible to disaggregate some
of that data geographically um as
well thanks
Daniel Council a ward yes thank you very
much um yeah just just quickly
reflecting on Council newport's question
page
22 um I have no idea what the size of
this place we're sitting in it could be
3,000 square meters but it would
certainly fit small theater Museum or
you know mediumsized Health fitness
facility and a bingo club so uh maybe
this is something that he had in the
back of his mind as part of what he was
thinking but if I can just just come on
to something else if I may chairman is
is just as a real EST thing as an
overall thing um I know it has been
bought up in regards to um our director
of place moving on and I'm just
wondering in Daniel's estimation have
the risks increased for the
delivery of the local plan
um with reference you know to the
housing numbers and I I do that
specifically um there are lots of
circumstances that are now out of our
control obviously we've lost uh a senior
man uh we are planning to go to
submission uh quarter 2
2025 and we have a possible general
election in
2024 now I just wonder with a possible
change in government and and a possible
change of direction for how can I put it
that particular government whoever they
may be in regards to housing
numbers if they do come in with a large
change in housing
numbers would that would we would that
affect us or would we be in a place far
enough down the road to be able to
counteract
it I thought you asked that question at
the last meeting actually no I didn't
you sure
yeah I think all I can say to that
chairman is that you know clearly we
monitor risk the program all the time
but I think in a in a sense there is
already planning reform you know on the
table that we are taking account of um
so longer term changes to planning
reform are not necessarily something
that we can easily
contemplate um but in a general sense
clearly we're cognizant of risks and we
you know carry on being cognizant of
risks um in that context I not to jump
around but I did just want to come back
and correct my former self and say
actually it looks like in table 4.1 and
4.2 probably elsewhere in the report
there is already a geographic breakdown
or some of that need um so you don't
need to go to the appendix to the
appendix just the appendix I think will
will suffice um but apologies just so
just to cover off councelor board's
question um I mean we're we're always
aware of the risks but I think at the
moment we my instinct is that a local
plan will be a local plan under any
system um and we there's not enough
certainty at the moment to really um be
able to contemplate what a different
system might mean um you know we'll
progress at the program we can ay
progress that I
think I might add to that I said I think
the task we've got setting us already is
tough enough without post what may or
might happen take the point but we've
got to get on with what we've got um and
those uh issues whe whether they come up
or not in the future we'll deal with
them then
okay I'm just asking do we have the
flexibility to actually move our
submission to the inspectors
forward I mean what what I would advise
is that I think the priority should be
try to formulate the preferred options
draft as quickly as we can but that does
mean obviously accounting for the
evidence Bas that's currently under
preparation and and the kind in due
process clearly I don't think we can
really contemplate timetable changes
beyond that stage at this point but I
would say it's probably a clear role for
the planning policy committee to monitor
that time table and obviously if there
are opportunities then then to do that
but the key time time time table
dependency as I've probably said in
previous meetings is the evidence base
and it's not something generally that
trying to do it quicker will lead to a
better result and so in that sense
there's always a balance to be struck um
so yes I mean I would just advise
chairman that we carry on with the work
we're doing and aim to kind of reach
preferred options uh as soon as we can
um allowing for due process in the
evidence
base thank you D okay
are there any more questions if not I'd
like to move on to noting this
report not well noted
noted okay thank you that concludes the
agenda business I've just got one more
announcement to make uh for members to
be aware um in November there will be
another planning policy get together it
may well be a formal meeting or it may
well be a workshop that will be
dictated U by events um and we will let
you know when where and the style of the
meeting as soon as possible but please
be aware there will be action in
November thank you chairman could I just
ask may as we running into November and
in particularly December our diaries for
all of us start fill up very very
rapidly I know mine is pretty much loads
of functions well not so much functions
as meetings squeeze them in so can we
have notification of the meeting Dan and
I spoke about it today and it will
come thank you everybody the
meeting you
Meed this meeting closed at 2037 thank
you
[Music]
everybody